how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and of
course all things relating to the MCU
today we have some super exciting news
about Ghost Rider coming to the MCU
ghost rider has had quite the ride when
it comes to the big screen and the
silver screen being played by Nicolas
Cage in the 2007 adaptation and then
again in 2012 Ghost Rider spirit of
vengeance and then in the Marvel
television show agents of shield Gabriel
Luna played Robbie Reyes who was
actually pretty well received but we've
never really truly had a Ghost Rider in
the MCU
yes Ghost Rider was in agents of shield
and agents of shield was affected by the
events of the MCU but with the exception
of Agent Coulson we never saw any of the
characters from agents of shield appear
in any of the MCU films but it appears
as if that is going to change as we have
some reports that say Marvel Studios is
developing a ghost writer project right
now and to top it all off there's a
rumor going around right now that Keanu
Reeves could be the person they cast to
play ghost writer so we'll break down
these reports if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU also for
this week's giveaway I'm giving away an
Iron Man Funko pop so all you have to do
is subscribe like the video and comment
about the video down below to enter so
today we have two reports from two
credible sources that have been write
about many things in the past that say
ghost writer is being developed at
Marvel Studios as we speak this report
comes from Daniel Richmond who says the
project is going to be set in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and a titular
character will not be the version
portrayed by Gabriel Luna like we saw in
agents of shield currently right now
it's uncertain if the Ghost Rider
project is a feature film or a
live-action series now we know that Hulu
was developing a Ghost Rider series
however it was scrapped so it could be
possible that they are developing
another series but they could perhaps
put it on Disney Plus or Hulu again but
then we got a second report from Charles
Murphy and in a tweet he said Secret
Invasion Young Avengers ironheart all
100% legit projects being developed and
then he added in another tweet and you
can add Ghost Rider back onto that list
as well it is happening so Ghost Rider
is happening although these reports say
that they're not sure whether it's going
to be a feature film or
a Disney plush show or a hula show we
did get a report about a month ago from
the famous leaker Roger Wardell Roger
Waddell was the person who leaked a ton
of stuff about Avengers in Game months
in advance that all ended up becoming
true so clearly he is somebody with
inside information and a month ago he
leaked that Ghost Rider was going to
appear in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness this is something
that was kind of expected by fans
especially if we consider the fact that
Doctor Strange 2 is really going to
explore the more mystic side of the MCU
now they didn't quite specifically
mention which Ghost Rider is going to be
coming to the MCU however Daniel
Richmond's report did state that it is
not going to be Robbie Reyes so this
could be the perfect opportunity for the
introduction of Johnny Blaze to the MCU
and the reason that Johnny Blaze would
make the most sense is because of his
connection to mephesto there are a lot
of signs that mephesto could be making
his way to the MCU and not to mention
that Roger Waddell said that Johnny
Blaze and Captain Britain in Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness
will pave the way for Doctor Doom to
arrive who also has a connection to
mephesto as well and the comics Johnny
Blaze gets his powers by agreeing to
give his soul to Satan and Satan would
eventually go on to be revealed as the
Archdemon
mephesto he made this deal with him to
save the life of his dying father and
these powers turned him into Ghost Rider
one of the most powerful Marvel
characters that we've ever seen in fact
in the world war hulk story Doctor
Strange himself said that Ghost Rider
might be equally as powerful as the
green scar persona of the Hulk and could
even defeat him but mephesto also has a
connection to the Wanda vision series as
we've seen some leaked photos that
they're going to explore the Salem witch
trials and in the 1 division series it's
speculated that we could see Cynthia Von
Doom the mother of Victor Von Doom aka
Doctor Doom and the comics mephesto ends
up tricking Cynthia Von Doom and he ends
up trapping her inside of his realm
essentially hell now Victor Von Doom aka
dr. doom was raised in the magical arts
and he was able to contact his mother in
the other realm and when he became
powerful enough he challenged mephesto
he said that if he could defeat him he
would release his mother to this day he
has not yet defeated him but you can see
the strong connection
here and we do know that the Scarlet
Witch is going to be in dr. strange in
the multiverse of madness so when this
report says that dr. strange in the
multiverse of madness is going to pave
the way for dr. Doom's arrival to the
MCU they could be referring to mephesto
because he has that connection with
Johnny Blaze The Scarlet Witch and
Doctor Doom and not to mention another
reason that we think that Ghost Writer
is going to appear in Doctor Strange too
is that Kevin Feige made a very
interesting comment recently about a new
character that we've never seen that
they've wanted to put in the MCU for a
while now appearing a few months ago in
an interview speaking about Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness he
said sometimes you're choosing a title
hero choosing which main character or
which main team and oftentimes it's as
you're making and developing the movie
asking who will come into it and who
will fit into it the next Doctor Strange
film for instance features some new MCU
characters that will be making their
debut in that movie you won't expect and
you won't guess who it is
but we found a cool way to make it work
because we want to make a particular
type of movie there and there was a
character that we always wanted to do
something with that will fit really well
there and that's a direct quote from
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios the person who develops all
these projects so based off of what
Kevin Feige has said and based off of
these reports that we got it seems like
Ghost Rider may be making his debut and
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
mandus but then he may go on to have his
own movie or show but there have been
some rumors going around about who could
possibly play Ghost Rider and if these
rumors end up being true then it's
definitely going to be a movie and the
reason is because the rumors say that
Keanu Reeves is being eyed to play Ghost
Rider I actually think that this would
be a pretty epic role for Keanu Reeves
to play in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but if Keanu Reeves comes onboard to the
MCU to play Ghost Rider it's not going
to be in a television show this is an
extremely busy guy this is a guy that
has two movies the matrix four and John
wick for releasing to theaters on the
same exact day
it's very improbable that he would sign
on to do multiple episodes and possibly
even seasons of a show
and if Marvel Studios finally does
decide to cast Keanu Reeves as a role
they're most likely gonna want
to debut on the big screen and the great
thing is is that we do know 100% that
Keanu Reeves is at least being
considered for the role of Ghost Rider
and the reason is Kevin Feige basically
came out and said this Kevin Feige came
out and said that they talked to Keanu
Reeves about every Marvel project they
have going on they're basically just
trying to find the exact perfect project
for him many of you probably know that
they did this exact same thing with Jake
Gyllenhaal and his role for Mysterio
they talked to Jake Gyllenhaal all the
time about many different roles in the
MCU that he could play but they never
settled on a perfect fit for him that is
until the role of Mysterio came along
they decided that it was the perfect
role for him and they cast him and they
were one hundred thousand percent right
so they do the same thing for Keanu
Reeves they talked to him about every
role that they have coming up in every
possible project so you already know
that they're going to be talking to him
about Ghost Rider now as far as Johnny
Blaze actually being introduced in
Doctor Strange and multiverse of madness
there are a few different ways this
could happen one is that they could
simply introduce him in the current time
he could appear randomly showing up just
to help Doctor Strange or other allies
they probably wouldn't do much of a
story arc for him as they're most likely
to save that origin story for his film
or series so he could simply just show
up as a magical character to add to
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness another way that he could show
up is by a connection to the Wanda
vision series we already know that Wanda
is going to be creating a lot of
different realities in fact we've
already seen a small glimpse of this and
a teaser that they gave us
vision residence now in the comics want
to take some characters from one reality
and brings them into another and this
could be one scenario of how Ghost Rider
could come into the MCU Wanda could
create Ghost Rider for whatever reason
and bring him into the main timeline and
that could be part of the multiverse of
madness so to speak that Doctor Strange
is going to have to clean up and again
if they do in fact someone introduced
mephesto in Wanda vision that's a
perfect segue for Ghost Rider to be
introduced in that series or in
multiverse of madness and then the final
way that he could be introduced is
pretty simple he could simply come from
another universe Wanda is creating
different realities and the Avengers and
Avengers in game created multiple
timelines there are going to be many
different alternate universes timelines
and realities and Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and Johnny Blaze
Ghost Rider could come from one of these
three and perhaps Doctor Strange may be
able to help him in one way or another
and that causes him to stay in our main
timeline now all of these options still
offer a way to do an origin story if he
shows up in multiverse of madness they
probably won't reveal too much about his
origin probably just reveal the fact
that he made a deal with mephesto to get
his powers or some other type of demon
this will offer plenty of room for a
movie or a show to explore the true
origin of Ghost Rider and of course as
we know Marvel is heading towards the
cosmic future and now that we know that
Marvel is planning on introducing Ghost
Rider to the MCU we could possibly be
getting cosmic Ghost Rider in the future
but before that Ghost Rider is entering
the MCU what do you all think about this
and do you think Keanu Reeves would be a
good fit for Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider
if you have an idea of how Ghost Rider
could enter Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness let me know down
below in the comments be sure to like
this video and subscribe with
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
don't forget for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching we'll forth